i am the ceo of astia and we'll get to
more of that shortly but let me find out
about you if i might it'll just help me
frame my talking points for you
raise your hand if you are sitting next
to a woman
okay
raise your hand if you are not a man
that's helpful raise your hand if you
are an entrepreneur already while you're
here and studying
okay raise your hand if you hope to be
an entrepreneur
raise your hand if you have not yet
raised your hand
okay good
i love it okay those of you who just
raised your hand i expect questions at
the end so that you're fully engaged i
need to know that you're awake and not
falling asleep on me i'm going to
apologize in advance i was confessing to
tina i'm a bit jet-lagged so if it
starts to get dull one of you people who
just raise your hand you raise your hand
and you tell me to move on
okay so i've learned
a long time ago
that you at the start of my talk will
want to hear
what i'm going to talk about that'll
help you see your way to the end it'll
help you see your way to your if you're
going for drinks for dinner whatever's
after this and you'll know when i'm
going to be done so let's talk about my
talk really quickly and then we'll move
into it we're going to talk about why
innovation matters
we're going to talk about how you too
can create a culture of innovation
that's not something just unique to
silicon valley but it is something that
certainly must be thought about and
cultivated and we're going to talk about
how you do that
and then i'm going to talk to you about
why in particular the high growth
economy is ripe for this conversation of
inclusive innovation
and when we're talking high growth
that's my purview
we're talking venture backable
high-tech clean tech life science
companies you know the next gen end text
the next googles the next twitters
those are the types of companies we're
talking about in my conversation and i'm
sure that there are other learnings for
other spectrums of the economy but i'm
going to be very specific to the high
growth economy in my comments
so
as a leader in this specific space i've
spent a lot of time contemplating
leadership for today leadership for
tomorrow and what i should contribute to
the big challenges in front of us
and one of my first learnings in that
contemplation was that
as leaders
we're leading in a time of truly
unprecedented change now i know we've
said that before in history but if you
think about almost every move or
decision a leader makes today
ripples around the world in a
stroke of a tweet tweet
in the flip of a youtube video
everything i'm saying i'm sure will be
commented on publicly by others who
watch the video before i even have time
to clarify what i meant to say
this is a time of
profound ability to have impact
and within that i've chosen to be a
heretic
i think that in times especially like
this of unprecedented impact you must
have people questioning what is what's
accepted what we've been told
and i stand firmly in that space
you will have heard things because
you're here at one of the best
institutions and you will believe them
to be true because you heard them here
at stanford and i'm actually going to be
bold enough to say some of it
isn't true
some of it needs to be challenged by you
as you become a leader as you move out
to become your best entrepreneur you can
be as you go on to become whatever it is
as you go back to finland you have to
dare to look at everything with a
critical eye because everything is under
change challenge and questioning
so that's me
you've gotten to know me a little bit
and i said i was going to talk to you
about innovation so let me tell you why
you can ignore me
because as it relates to the very
economy that i have chosen to focus on
i am not
a high-growth
entrepreneur never have been one
i have not
successfully grown a company to ipo or
to m a
so i'm actually possibly the least
qualified person at stanford to talk to
you about this economy
and add to it i have my masters in
public policy it makes me completely
useless
according to
the vast majority of those looking for
thought leadership in the space of high
growth entrepreneurship
but here's why you can listen to me
i've been a student of silicon valley
throughout my entire career since i
moved here in 1991
and as a student i was able to
move away from what i was told
and challenge that and actually look at
what was really happening
and there are some interesting layers to
this onion called silicon valley
some layers that are worth exploring
and i'm going to share a bit about that
with you today
so let's start by doing a level set
you are all extremely bright people so i
know that we all you all sitting there
have a definition for innovation
excuse me but i'm going to tell you why
i believe innovation matters and why
it's worth some thought leadership and
some big think
jobs
we have just emerged from the worst
financial crisis since the great
depression
day after day we read accounts of how we
are slowly emerging from that but we
have yet to seen the the jobs recovery
that normally flows with the economic
recovery
as someone who studies economies this is
a problem
and it's a big problem as it relates to
the innovation economy because even
where there are jobs we're not seeing
the talent that can fill the next
level of jobs the innovation jobs
so all the way around innovation matters
because it's the job engine
all net new jobs in the last 30 years
were created by high growth companies in
the first five years of growth
wow
did anyone even know that
i was shocked to find that out because
by the way most people like to focus on
corporations to create jobs or even
small business
but this was an aha that was discovered
about a year and a half ago by the
kaufman foundation it's worth thinking
about how innovation
could solve
that job creation hurdle especially when
we know that all of the net new jobs in
the last and most recent economic
history
came from these high growth companies
innovation matters on another upfront
and that has to be a very personal
friend
those of you who raised your hand
because you're already an entrepreneur
you already know this
innovation matters to you at a gut level
that you can't deny
for those of you aspiring to be an
entrepreneur if you don't have that gut
level
those are hard times in front of you
you got to find that thing that really
motivates you
for me
my alignment with innovation
came out of that
cryolife is an interesting company you
probably have never heard has anyone
here heard of cryolife
for me it's my google
back in 2003 i had this silly problem
called fainting i was diagnosed by some
of the most brilliant cardiologists
around the world with a common faint and
was told it would go away in time when i
stopped being so hysterical
and fortunately there were innovators
who dared to challenge that and where
they were looking at women's heart
health
who knew that women's hearts function
differently than men today i stand here
with one of those fantastic valves
inside of me
that has been beautifully engineered by
another human being harvested by
cryolife and put into me but that would
not have happened without the innovators
at cryolife who journeyed since 1984
through clinical trials through raising
a venture capital through that horrible
long journey of innovation to the
fantastic result
of saving a life
this is why i love innovation
and it's why i'm so bound to you
entrepreneurs and so dedicated to
helping you get
the ecosystem right
so that you can succeed whoever the you
is
okay we've established innovation
matters
both on a global level and on a very
personal level
there are ways to create ecosystems
environments
communities
and there are ways to do it
to ensure that you achieve innovation
what you might not know is that there's
actually an abundant body of research
about how to do it
what i find most profoundly interesting
is that very little of it gets applied
i spoke about a month and a half ago at
mit where the research the original
research was done
and in the audience were people who
hadn't even heard of it and it was out
of mit
so i'm here to share with you
other direction
i'm here to share with you this
incredible learning that i learned at
ibm centennial at ibm centennial they
did this coolest thing they brought 750
leaders from around the world brought us
together in a room to hear all of the
best thinking on some of the hardest
topics
innovation being but one of them and
professor tom alone from mit did this
amazing talk
mit had determined or was determined to
find out what led to an innovative
culture within an organization and how
to create a model that could be
replicated across teams so that you
weren't just randomly hoping that you'd
get innovation and that you'd get smart
performance and you'd get results but
you could actually measure it as you
measure individual intelligence
and you could predict its results
the most profound finding was that they
discovered that iq which we've been
measuring for nearly half over half a
century actually
had no correlation to group intelligence
so it didn't matter how smart the people
you put together it did not then result
in a smarter team
so they went a step further and said
well what does what are the things that
we can continue to measure what are the
metrics we should be
driving towards
to get to the best innovation to get to
the smartest teams
and this is the stuff this is the jewel
of my talk so everyone wake up now we're
gonna talk about what they found they
found three things
that determined group intelligence
so everyone better be writing and typing
number one
the average social perceptiveness of the
group
how well do they read each other's body
language
can i tell that you're bored
did i notice that you're laughing at me
did i notice you've completely bought
into what i'm saying because you're not
in your head these were the things that
were a measure
of how smart a group
interesting
second was
the evenness of the conversation
did the group argue with each other
or did they dialogue
did they share ideas or did they squoosh
ideas
my husband throughout my my journey in
silicon valley has been at seven
startups
he's cto at most of them
and he's not a programmer himself but he
somehow ends up in these programmer
cultures over and over and over again
and he and i talk about in point number
two a lot because he himself is fairly
mild-mannered and fairly soft-spoken but
put him in a silicon valley startup
that's tech back and back excuse me a
tech company that's venture-backed
and suddenly what he merges is this
aggressive nature that argues your way
and gets your point across because
everyone else is an idiot and i'm gonna
take you to where the smartness is
interesting mit found that that's not
the way to get to
the best code
okay so now the third thing
is something that was truly shocking
i mentioned i learned this at ibm
centennial
probably about 10 maybe 20 of us in the
audience were women
so it was a very large gathering of a
lot of suits
and when point number three came up
the room erupted
two kinds of eruptions the women stood
and cheered
and the men stood and cheered
this was a really interesting finding
the proportion of women on the group
directly contributed correlated to
the group's intelligence
and its subsequent performance
and the innovation it was able to
achieve
now mit has done this research backward
forward and continued to prove it
the university of michigan scott page
has done very similar research same
findings
stanford clayman institute has done
similar research same findings
and yet walk into any venture firm today
find if there's a woman in the
partnership
and you'd be amazed to learn that five
percent
of venture capital partners are women
for an industry that loves its data
and makes its decisions around that data
this stuff seems so easy to implement
within the teams that you invest in and
the teams you create as a venture firm
and yet it's the last
the last bit of research that
really doesn't get moved forward so i'm
here as the heretic in the room to say
all of those hiring practices you know
you've heard them hire someone smarter
than yourself
hire the best person you can the best
person for the job the smartest person
for the job the top of his class his or
her class
and yet really if you think about hiring
for your organization
we were talking about this earlier
weren't we organizations how do
organizations cultures get created
well not on accident
they get chosen
and you can choose this
for your ecosystem whatever that is if
it's a company you're starting
if it's an environment you're creating
if it's a community you're engaging in
interesting learnings
worth thinking about
the impact goes well beyond the
individual group performance though too
i mentioned i'm a public policy wonk
i really don't do anything without data
and what i am struck by is once again
the data defends
making sure you got woman in there
and it's not because the women have a
right to be in there it's because you by
the way would be smart to put them in
there the economic impact is profound
just today in the economist there was a
fantastic article about the impact
should women be able to fully
participate as entrepreneurs globally
you know they ranked in this economist
article the countries where women had
full access and full participation to
entrepreneurship and the us isn't even
doesn't even make the top ten list
and would you be surprised to know that
women
if they were able to fully participate i
love this bit of data
this is from um secretary of state
clinton
she had mckinsey goldman sachs take a
look at what are the numbers if women
just who were at the ready women already
educated here at stanford fully
participated in the economy to their
full potential
a very nice impact to the economy
equal to
greater than
an investment in the people of china and
india combined
just by tapping into the women who are
already at the ready this isn't a
pipeline conversation this is a
potential conversation
something to talk about
but it leads me to ask you
which is
where i started i'm ceo of astia
and
what astia is is a little bitty social
experiment
so the other thing i didn't tell you
about me
is i take my learnings
and i try
to solve what i see to be
problems that i've identified
opportunities around
anasta is a very specific endeavor
when i came out of my graduate program
i had taken a look at women's
participation in emerging markets
i thought there was a real problem with
women's access to capital in ethiopia
and sudan
and kenya and name any sub-saharan
africa country
what i was stunned to find was that at
the time that i finished my graduate
thesis
silicon valley had fewer women in it
than any of those countries
participating in the economy
did
two percent of venture capital at that
time went to women's ceos
astounding
unfortunate if you ask me especially as
i look around and see these brilliant
women here
my goal is to help
you as students
see the opportunity
to help the ecosystem see the
opportunity but better yet i'm not going
to wait for it i'm going to do it myself
so let me tell you about astia
as tina mentioned asti is a global
community it's 5 000 strong around the
globe
but here's where we're really unique
we are half men
and half women
exactly half and half
always exactly half and half
my board half men and half women my
advisory boards in each market half men
and half women
the advisor teams that we create for the
companies half men and half women
and you might say why
and we touched on this earlier too
the why is a really interesting one
what i've learned about communities
is that within any given community there
are always some people who are more
outside of the norm than others
and that leaves them feeling
uncomfortable
but when everyone's kind of on an equal
footing of
outside the norm
at asda men are kind of outside the norm
it's an organization for you heard tina
focused on women-led high-growth
companies
but so are the women because we're
talking venture capital
so everyone feels a little bit outside
the norm
i call it getting comfortable with
uncomfortable
because ultimately if i were to redesign
the high growth economy
i would be striving towards everyone
being equally uncomfortable
it's where you kind of sit on your edge
just a little bit
you kind of get
into that space of listening a little
bit better because you're not sure
and when everyone is equally unsure
you get some really exciting and juicy
stuff happening and we see it at astia
all of the time
interestingly
in my unique space we focus on what
entrepreneurs need
it's pretty straightforward it's not
complicated none of this is rocket
science they need access to networks
they need access to opportunity so let's
talk about how this plays out in an
astia ecosystem
because i mentioned we're all a bit
navigating something new and
uncomfortable so access to networks
let's start there
pretty straightforward you need to raise
capital you're going to need to meet
with investors you're going to need to
present to them and get them to believe
in you and invest in you
and you're going to need
access to other entrepreneurs and
industry leaders who can provide you
expertise
seems pretty straightforward seems like
anyone could do that
the barrier there that's interesting or
the hurdle there that's interesting is
that in our society
men and women are still in separate
business networks
so let's think about that what does that
mean that we're in separate business
networks well it means
let's say i got fired tomorrow
i can think of five people i would call
immediately and all of them happen to be
women
let's say something really amazing
happened to you tomorrow
like in your career you were promoted to
head of grand pupa of google whatever
that is
you odds are if you were speaking
statistically would have five men who
you would call
interesting
these gender lines
exist for some really interesting
social normative behaviors like sex
right
it's very uncomfortable to get into
intimate business relationships because
across gender there might be sexual
attraction there might be a partner at
home who finds it uncomfortable lots of
reasons for it to exist this isn't glass
ceiling stuff but it is socially
validated stuff
and when we hearken back to what i said
earlier that 95 of venture partners are
men
and we know that
to get access to those men you need to
have access to their trusted business
network you can see how for a female
entrepreneur that might be a harder
journey
take it a step further and actually dare
to talk about hidden bias we all know
that it early
stage investment
we don't have a lot to rely on there
aren't customers yet lots of times
there's not even a product so we use
words like i believed that entrepreneur
i trusted that entrepreneur i
knew that i could get into a 10-year
relationship with that entrepreneur
wake up at midnight take their call and
feel really good
about that investment i made
all of those words start to break down
across networks and not just for women
for anyone who's on the outside
of a fairly tight ecosystem which is
what venture capital is
so while what entrepreneurs need on
access to networks is identical across
gender how it plays out is not identical
because 95 percent of vcs are men which
god love them i love that they invest in
entrepreneurs i told you i love
innovation i'm alive because of
innovation but we can see how there
might have to be an extra effort to
figure out how to go for that glass of
wine
or that martini if you're talking to me
at about 10 o'clock at night
when he's supposed to be at home
with his kids or his wife or whomever or
worse heaven forbid someone walks into
the bar who actually knows both of us
and wonders what the two of us are doing
having a martini at 10 o'clock at night
it gets hard
it's hard stuff
i like that you're nodding thank you
anyone who can't figure that out or
can't understand that should try it one
time i'm happy to go for a martini with
you okay so
access to opportunity i think we've
nailed why the network's part is hard
let's talk about access to opportunity
well what's interesting about
opportunity is it's about
having the aspiration to high growth
entrepreneurship as well as
understanding the path to success
so let's take them apart
aspiration
claim an institute did a great bit of
research and by the way you should be
googling claimant institutes they have
great research around everything i've
said
but this one is really interesting they
took a look at why women were dropping
out of math and sciences and this
research was originally done at the
university of wisconsin-madison
replicated here at stanford a lot
smarter people than me doing this stuff
guys
what they found was that a young man
getting
the phase in a calculus course
getting a b
feels like he's doing fine getting a c
he's doing fine
all the way down to a d he's not only
fine he is brilliant he's a math whiz
he's going to use it in the furtherance
of his career he's going to negotiate a
higher salary because he knows calculus
young woman same class
can go down to a b
before she feels like she's failed
she's very likely at that b
to drop math as a major
so drop the calculus course without
completing it
to never mention to a soul that she took
that calculus course and got that
horrible grade
you can understand how that
mentality
results in lower aspirations
that lower self-assessment
it's interesting how often i tell this
story and i see people nodding at me and
saying yeah i've done that i've felt
like i've failed when maybe i haven't
men never feel that
statistically speaking
that's the unique purview of what
society has done to little girls
that results in different paths to
success
women are extremely entrepreneurial we
have started
we are starting businesses at five times
the rate of men
raising 1 27th the capital that men are
so our paths to success
are not nearly as
high
falutin for lack of a better word
and while we try things
we try them in a more conservative
approach because we're not necessarily
sure that we're the one who can deliver
on that
what's been really cool about astia
is how this plays out when you finally
hit men and women doing this together
because men sitting next to a woman
who under assesses her ability correct
her
i have this fantastic story that i
always tell about prashant shaw at
hummer winblad he was at the time the
astia board chair
hummer wind blood is one of the most
laudable venture firms in the valley and
that prashant was willing to serve as my
board chair was something i was very
grateful for but i'm far more grateful
for what he did for this one
entrepreneur and he did it for many but
this one in particular was interesting
she was a young woman who had
successfully run a hedge fund for 15
years
she was presenting her business at one
of our showcases
and the room was filled with investors
and she presented
and hum and prashant raised his hand and
he said i notice on your market slide
your total addressable market slide
the numbers seem a little off
it looks to me like you have
underestimated the true market size
and she said no no i didn't
underestimate it this is what i can
deliver to you
and he said what do you mean that's what
you can deliver to me
and she said well i know the market size
is actually about four times this
but i know that i could deliver to you
this market
and he's
he because he's astia stayed in the
conversation he said you understand that
total addressable market nobody's
expecting you to get the whole thing
you can put up a number that's more than
what you are going to get she said no no
i couldn't do that
it was a fantastic astia moment because
in that moment
prashant understood
that when women come to present to him
and it's played out over and over and
again
odds are they're going to have more
subdued numbers
for lack of a better word
they're going to be
stated in a way that reflects the ceo's
understanding of her ability to deliver
that but when a young man presenting the
same business
presents he will present a true total
addressable market whether or not he can
achieve it
and all prashant has to do in that
moment is stay in the conversation and
talk to her about that because then she
adjusted her slides and all she had to
do in that moment was stay in the
conversation and learn what prashant was
expecting to hear from her
mit excuse me harvard just finished a
report that came out a week ago
um validating also that it's not just
that we understate our numbers as women
we also are perceived as less
able and that's brand new so i haven't
had a whole lot of time to read it
except it's quite similar to the heidi
royce and howard raising case that you
might remember tina which is quite
interesting
and what that found was that when you
put forward a business case with a man's
name on it and you have a male present
it
there's a perception that it's an
investable deal this exact same business
case presented by a woman's voice with a
woman's name on it
has a uh far less likelihood of getting
funded
and from what i have read in the cursory
of that because i haven't had the time
to read the whole thing yet is that it's
40 less likely to get funded
i don't think the way to address that is
to go individually beating up every
investor and telling them to stop it
i think the far more interesting and
exciting thing to do is to redesign the
ecosystem so that men and women are in
it together pursuing these very same
things that they need
but doing it in a way that everyone's
just a bit uncomfortable in figuring out
what the other person intended to say
what the other person meant to say
doing those best behaviors that we heard
from mit
intuiting each other
putting some intonation behind
understanding what the body language is
saying staying in the conversation and
daring to find out if that person
might actually be worthy of investment
not because of your perceptions and your
gut feeling and your hunch but maybe
because you've had a broader
understanding of the full opportunity of
that entrepreneur
i don't know just my thinking
okay
so why i think in particular this
conversation could happen here
in a culture that loves innovation
and yet hasn't achieved inclusive
innovation
you heard me say that when i finished my
research two percent of venture capital
went to women's ceos today it's five
still not much better
and i'm sure you're all seeing the
articles that say why the dearth of
women entrepreneurs and i just wish we
could tip the question on its head and
instead of asking why the dearth of
women entrepreneurs
how do we create
an ecosystem
that's inclusive
or an inclusive innovation
i think it's a far more interesting
question
because
let's talk about where we are
women are half of the workforce for
goodness sake
for the first time ever we've finally
hit this great and laudable goal of
women in the workforce firmly
so if ever there was a time in a place
that we could talk about creating
inclusive innovation it seems now
i also think
nationally we're at an exciting time for
women broadly you know we're 57 of the
undergraduate population
it would seem that we could move well
past five percent of venture capital
going to women
ceos
stanford this is what you look like
still pretty darn good
to me it seems ripe opportunity stuff
this is my challenge though
this is women at stanford studying the
stems
oh no because that matters here in the
valley doesn't it we keep hearing this
not enough women in the sciences
there is no reason for this statistic
when we know that women are
over half of the phds we are over half
of the mds we are over half of the law
students why are we so few there i don't
know but i think we need to ask the
larger question about why
is that environment a place
where we aren't
then there's my astia challenge to you
this last year i dove into the numbers
we've made it to a whopping seven
percent
of companies with venture backing
that have a woman in a founding position
my challenge to you if you are women in
the room
and if you didn't raise your hand on
that entrepreneurial question
reconsider it
you're at one of the most
incredible institutions to become an
entrepreneur you'll have the networks
you'll have the pedigree you'll have the
opportunity
if you're a man in the room and you
haven't added a woman to your team or
haven't already solved it because you
saw my earlier information about women i
can introduce you to some of your fellow
classmates they should be on your team
they're brilliant
they just might not know it or they
might present it differently than you do
if you're not a student but instead
you're a professor at stanford i
encourage you
when you look at your course
construction be sensitive to the fact
that if only one group in your class is
uncomfortable
that one group is going to become
smaller and smaller and smaller
and that's what we've seen in the
boardroom in the corporate executive
room and quite honestly anywhere where
network matters we've seen the numbers
declining for women not increasing in
the last 30 years
and then finally if you're an industry
leader and you're in the room or you're
watching the podcast you have a lot you
can do to contribute to the ecosystem as
well
i always say i hate quotas but i love
the results and bill campbell has a
phenomenal way to get to results for any
ecosystem he said that when he was ceo
of intuit and he had an opening
he would require that half of the
resumes he considered be women
not because he was going to favor women
but because he knew that half of the
population that was ready for that
opportunity
was women
sounds a lot like counting in quotas
but it actually
is going back to a learning
which is having women in those roles
matters
matters to business performance it
matters to innovation
it matters to jobs
and it's worth figuring out
why they're not there and what you've
done
to exclude them to not include them or
to not participate
raise your hand if you actually would
have come to this talk tonight if it was
optional and it was labeled women in
technology
thank you women for coming to my lecture
and one man
this isn't a conversation for women by
women
this is a conversation for the ecosystem
and this will not be solved
until we all
figure out what is our role
in this conversation mine i choose to be
heretic
i don't believe that there aren't women
in tech
qualified for the twitter board i don't
believe that there aren't women
qualified for any board in this valley
and i don't believe
that this can go on another generation
without being solved by smart people
like you
you guys are the leaders of tomorrow i'm
just going to ride on your coats
it's my hope that as you're finding your
path
you'll dare to adjust to reassess
what you've been told
silicon valley is not a meritocracy
well it's a worthy goal
a meritocracy
hasn't been achieved anywhere
so let's put that myth aside
and figure out
how we could get to a meritocracy
i am dying for a conversation with all
of you
how about we move to some q a
better yet how about you tell me some
things that you've learned that i might
learn from
i open up
yes
can you imagine that
the proportion of women on the team was
like
but what what proportion is ideal yeah i
really like that question because i
asked and i dove into the research and
unfortunately it's all the way up to 100
um
i don't think that's any better than 100
men personally but at least
algorithmically according to scott pages
it goes all the way up
i think that uh
there's probably more work around that
nuance and i actually think if you look
at points one and two uh for you know
evenness of the conversation and the
social perceptiveness we we train young
girls for that don't we i mean so i
think men could be trained in those
skills and attributes as well i think it
has far less to do with our genetic
makeup than how we socialize people
yes so what do you think of programs
like especially in the technology
industry that are specifically targeted
to women i think i asked you this
question before you never got to answer
it so the question is what i think of uh
programs that specifically target women
women in tech
i hate women's leadership programs i am
so done being mentored i am so done
having women be mentored so that's what
that's one um you know it's just i don't
need another mentor i got plenty of
advisors thank you very much and our
women are exceptional they don't need
mentoring they need advisors just like
anyone else does but i think often
mentoring or targeted programs are used
as a way to
fix women as it were rather than address
what is the issue that why aren't women
there and i'll give an example an
unnamed
uh partner of ours was really struggling
to get women in to their their program
for entrepreneurs so they wanted to
start a separate one for women
and they came to me and said we're going
to do this separate one for women it's
going to be awesome because the women
won't come to our current one and i said
well have you explored why they won't
come to your current one
well no no we're going to do this one
for women it's going to be great women
are going to show up and so they did
that
and they got a few women but not the
hundreds that they usually get for men
two years into this interesting dialogue
with them they've finally taken a look
at what was happening in their
organization to prevent women from from
participating
one was that they had an on location
requirement
okay the vast majority of women
have responsibilities in addition to
their work
and it is very difficult to go on
location anywhere
even if it's a weekend boot camp
and
they redesigned their program and moved
away from their three-month re on
location requirement and boom
their female applicants doubled
just by changing how they were doing
their program
so
things that try and fix women rather
than fix
the paradigm i'm very challenged by
having said that i do love my female
book club because we get together we
have a lovely glass of wine and we
mentor each other through whatever
hurdles we're having but i think there
are very few scenarios where a uniquely
focused women's effort will get us to
where we need to get because i actually
think it's a real this is a real problem
for us as a society and furthering it
with more and more women's only programs
i don't think gets us any closer to an
ultimate solution it's less comfortable
i think it is far more comfortable for
women to get together and feel all
womany and we like each other and that's
good but that's the same problem that
boys have when they all get together and
they feel good you know i just think
that
it's it's time for us to get
uncomfortable
does that answer your question
tina so to build on this a few weeks ago
startup weekend was at stanford and i
was there and was surprised and
disappointed by the fact that there were
very few women who showed up
and when they did show up they took a
back seat they took on roles that were
not leadership this was a place where
they nobody had to anoint them no one
had to invite them they could show up
and when we were talking about this
before you said there was was we could
change the design what could happen in a
program like that to make it more
attractive for women to show up in these
type of opportunities to start a venture
right so let's start with one myth
busting and then we'll go to another one
is that the average age of a successful
entrepreneur is 40.
and so a program that's a weekend and
that's men or women by the way and there
are fantastic exceptions and we all love
those fantastic exceptions because they
make a lot of money but the truth is
that the average age is 40. and startup
weekend if it's serious about starting
up new endeavors needs to be aware of
that data and know that a 40 year old
woman cannot leave home for the weekend
and the odds are she doesn't want to be
locked in
somewhere for a weekend now i love what
startup weekend does but i think that
if we're serious about starting
businesses you can't have one model
and say this will be the model for
starting a business you come lock
yourselves for a weekend or three months
or six months or whatever it is your
model actually has to have flexibility
because those
businesses are all very different and
the individuals behind them are very
different so that's myth number one it's
just the phenotype of the entrepreneur
and then the other one is that
that women feel included by the message
so without it being about startup
weekend i have read almost every
application for a startup and i will
tell you that most women would
opt out of applying because they don't
feel they're yet at the bar of that
application
you and i are talking about your
application i love your application
because it was very simple very little
to it
many have these bars that interestingly
women we've been socialized to follow
rules so if it asks us for our let's say
our valuation we don't know what that is
we assume we're not ready to apply
a young man will say i don't know what
evaluation is but i'm sure it's 10
million
and he'll apply and this is just what
we've done socially to girls and boys
differently
and it's part of why we should have the
discussion so i'm always when i see loan
numbers i'm always asking what was the
requirement to get there
astia we've moved to a nomination
process that 5000 member community they
source screen and select our companies
and sourcing is their number one job
because women do not apply and you're
right that's a problem we need to work
on because as a society we've created
that but that's not that those women
aren't capable and ready
sometimes they just need a nomination to
get them there
so once again we just adjusted our
process yes what's your advice
i have i have twin girls that are four
and i haven't told them yet anything
about this well i've i spent a lot of
time trying to encourage their
aspirations
and they have that but i'm worried that
they're going to go out in the world and
and find out oh they're supposed to have
the suppressed aspiration that horrifies
me at age seven yeah the research shows
that it'll happen at age seven and the
research also shows that you as daddy
have a huge role in that so it's great
that you are encouraging them to aspire
how many of you saw the goldilocks video
if you haven't seen it google it
we raise girls with some stupid
and i i mean it's just ridiculous how we
raise girls and while they're in your
control you're right you can you can
protect them from that and the second
they go go out they're gonna hear other
stupid stuff
i'll never forget the day my math
teacher
decided that math was for boys and said
it out loud
now i'm older than you guys so okay
maybe that's acceptable but i'm talking
not so long ago okay you're all born
after that so shut up but you know what
i'm saying i mean i just i worry too for
your daughters and it's why i think this
generation needs to get on this because
this isn't something that happens on
accident you cannot tell me that this is
because
silicon valley the meritocracy it is
doesn't see any women-led deals that's
ridiculous there is something bigger at
play and it's the stuff you're worried
about and i'm worried about it until we
get to the space where we're all okay
getting uncomfortable and every one of
you men who didn't raise your hand
because you weren't going to come to my
talk if it's called women in tech go to
those talks
dare to go be uncomfortable be the only
guy in the room
when when you meet a woman who's sitting
next to you in a class know that she's
feeling uncomfortable as you as
uncomfortable as you are
anyway i just think it's a larger
conversation that our society hasn't
geared up for yet and it's why i'm
committed to being the heretic and
saying until you're ready to talk about
it
in frank terms
sex
power money it's all there
and you've got to take it on and nobody
has solved this no one asti is the only
organization i can find that has hit 50
50 and the only thing close is the
israeli military
and interestingly they have a phenomenal
percentage of women high growth
entrepreneurs
not that we need a military i'm just
saying
anyone else yes
i was in a luncheon the other day with a
bunch of women we were talking about
women in leadership and i was a little
bit surprised by
a discussion around aping men women
succeeding by aping men
whether in body language personal
accessories
um you know putting on glasses sitting
with you know in a very like masculine
fashion
and i mean it disturbed me and i just
kind of wanted to get your feedback on
that so the question was about women
aping men
and quite honestly i'll go a step
further and say the programs that
encourage this because i cannot tell you
how many corporate executives i sit with
who tell me that their program for
women's leadership is to help them know
how to dress
how help them know how to talk help them
know how to do this
i find it so offensive women are not
broken i refuse to not wear my red dress
and my heels to this talk just because
most vcs would show up in their khakis
in their blue shirt
i like my red dress never mind that i
had to get the mic back there that was a
little bit hard
but you know what i mean i actually like
being a girl it's a pretty cool space we
have some strengths that are pretty darn
awesome if i can say so myself
but we spend so much time
re-defining
what success looks like so let me tell
you what success looked like when i was
four
four was i was going to be the best
ping-pong player ever
okay by the age of 12 my dad was telling
me my dad who by the way my dad's pretty
awesome told me i shouldn't beat boys
because it hurts their self-esteem
i bet every woman in this room has had
some sort of stupid advice like that and
if i ever hope to have a boyfriend
age 12.
anyway i'm pretty good at ping pong
but you know this stuff isn't easy stuff
and and when we go that's why we go to
the simple stuff
post industrial revolution
was white male single head of household
and we keep thinking that the models
that were created out of that somehow
are going to magically overnight
support dual household dual income
households with two kids
a nanny
soccer
all the things that go with that
you know when is there going to be an
executive that actually stands up and
says you know what i get it
that in the u.s today the number of
people i will employ who are single head
of host household
is is diminishing rapidly and is
definitely in the minority and therefore
i gotta think about the workplace
differently
i have yet to see that corporation stand
up and do it
because i think what they'd have to
address
is that their challenge of getting women
into the executive suites is about
networks and men and women aren't in the
same business networks those deals are
done over the golf course they are not
done when a headhunter comes in and says
oh you come into the executive suite
you can be the see whatever of our
company doesn't happen via hr people
that happens over a beer over martini on
the golf course and until we recognize
the barriers of networks
we won't get past it or we could do
quotas um i'm curious
you know kind of what the reality is of
women who
are excited and want to be
stay-at-home moms um or you know like
you said you're really excited about
wearing a red dress because you're
excited about being a girl what about
women who are excited about being a mom
and they really don't see like how is it
possible to actually be like the mom
that you want to be
and the per the and like the career
woman that you want to be where do you
so the question is uh
how do i balance this with women's
desire to be the best mom they could be
and here i'm a bit of a heretic as well
no i don't have children but that
doesn't stop me from having this advice
i don't believe that exists anymore
the absolute stay-at-home forever person
at some point you're going to have to
work and i mean sorry work outside the
home it is work in the home and i
apologize i said it that way but i think
it's naive to think that you can step
out for 15 years and miraculously come
back in
and women are all too often and their
husbands too naive about the impact to
career
and i think there's a better way to do
it there are board service there you
know there are board obligations that
you can maintain while raising children
and i think you know the heretic in me
really also bristles at being at
stanford and hearing that question
i got to tell you because
i don't want you to step out ever
you are tomorrow's leader you are my
next president of something and i want
you to be a fantastic mom and still be
able to go on that trajectory and i know
we can't get there without this
conversation
so
this is an interesting thing being at a
place like stanford i only speak to
really bright people because i think you
can solve it better than me
i don't know how to solve that but i
don't want you to step out
questions or thoughts
yes sir
so i think this last question
sets it up for me because you're
presenting a couple of challenges i mean
you're you're saying you don't want
to make that compromise you don't want
the students in this auditorium to make
that compromise
and in not making that compromise
you're setting up a model which frankly
there is very little evidence of it
actually working out
to date
but then you make the argument that the
ecosystem is not right and then there's
characteristics that women have that is
distinguished and distinct from men
and there's no value
associated with one versus the other but
they aren't different
and
entrepreneurship and innovation requires
a degree of ability to tolerate risk
which even amongst men is not universal
but that it self selects to a much
smaller
segment of the population
and so you you combine those two things
and you do end up with that kind of
ratio so i don't know i don't know what
compromise you're referencing i'm going
to ask you more about that but i am
going to take on the risk thing because
tina we had this conversation there is
no research that shows that women are
less tolerant than men there is great
research actually that take that says
that we just assess it differently
and we then do deal with it differently
sally crochet how many of you know sally
krawcheck is
right she was ceo and cfo at citibank so
she was ceo of private wealth and cfo of
city broadly and at the time of the
financial crisis she kept speaking up
and saying this risk is not worth our
journey
and they still went down that path and
she still stayed what she subsequently
did was unique to sally which was she
demanded that the risk they took didn't
get passed to their customers
so it wasn't that she
walked out of the game and it wasn't
that she somehow wouldn't stay there for
that difficult stuff but she did have a
different solution for what to do with
it
constantly i'm meeting women
entrepreneurs who are just as willing
and able to go on that entrepreneurial
journey and i go back to the research
there is no research to show that
there's a different risk tolerance there
is a different risk assessment
but the i'm more i'm more intrigued by
your opening comment which was uh the
compromise so what was your what was
your question
the question of the previous questioner
actually said you know if i want to be
a really good mom
uh i need to be able to make a choice i
mean they they would you say that to be
a really good mom you need to make it i
don't want to make sure that we're not
putting words in their mouth so you were
saying to be a really good mom you need
to choose between work and home
i don't know yet
but
yeah i mean what what do you do if you
want to be a really good mom and that's
what you see you have to do right now
how do you make it so are there any dads
in the room
okay so to be are you a good dad
yes okay
just checking i'm getting some advice
for you you're a good dad
have you had to choose between work and
home
yes how have you done that because
there's a woman asking for some advice
on this and i i am not a parent
we can take it offline he won't talk to
you about it
yes i am a mother of three kids all
under seven i worked at a big company
that raised 850 million dollars and i
wasn't management there but i reported
directly to management while pursuing a
phd at your school it's doable
okay and that's great and i love women
who can support women that i want to
hear from a man how you've managed to do
work and home because by the way this is
a difficult conversation
right thank you so is there a man who
will just tell me how uncomfortable it's
been or maybe it's been perfectly easy
yes sir
uh my wife and i made a choice where
living here in this valley she was
willing to sacrifice that for our son
and i'm very cognizant of the fact she's
made those sacrifices for herself
um and it's a challenge she's actually
trying to figure out right now how to
re-bring herself back into the workforce
in a place where she's really happy with
that amount of commitment on both sides
and it's very much not easy but i think
anyone in if you're in a relationship in
a two-parent household
the acknowledgement to the other that
they've given that sacrifice goes a long
way
that's a powerful statement
these are the conversations so these are
the things i don't have answers for i
just know that we got to get to the
conversation to get past this
because right now the only conversation
is why aren't there women why don't they
come and why do they drop out and i
think a far more enlightening exercise
would be
how do we get them there and how do we
keep them
thank you very much for your time
you